let's go next to ernest from missouri
ernest welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
uh hi david um i wanted to kind of
preface my question by saying i love the
way you engage with people who's
you don't necessarily agree with um
that's a skill i think that's lost uh in
the modern political debate or at least
is slipping away from us
what are some things
oh you're welcome uh what are your what
are some things you think we can do to
like encourage people to engage
in more civil debates and uh kind of to
broaden that out to get away from like
the talking point
and more on the issues at hand you know
my view on this shifts over time one of
the things i've been trying recently
is kind of putting it out there and you
people who have seen my appearances on
some places recently like the michael
knowles show and trigonometry might have
noticed that i did this i say up front
hey do are we on the same page that we
want to have a good faith debate and
we're not trying to do gotchas but we're
trying to really solve problems or find
shared understanding
even if the other person
doesn't have any plan to do that
usually they'll at least say that that's
their goal and then you can use that as
something to point back to and say hey
listen let's let's skip the talking
points we both said we wanted a good
faith conversation and we want to try to
find some answers
can't we just agree that x and it's sort
of a cheap rhetorical tool
but it might actually predispose people
to maybe come in with with a slightly
better attitude you know if you asked me
a year ago i might have had some
different technique that i was trying at
the time
another tool that can be useful
is
starting with where we agree so you know
you could have a very contentious issue
like
i don't know abortion or something like
that but you could first start with well
what what do we agree on we we agree
that murder is bad uh certainly on all
the instances where we agree as to what
murder is
we agree that we want uh people's uh
ability to
determine the best course for their life
is something that should be priority you
know you lay out all of these areas of
agreement and this can often kind of
really narrow the scope of the
disagreement in a way that it seems more
manageable so that's another idea but
that this is a really big topic and my
if you asked me in six months i might
have a different perspective
right um and so if you don't mind i kind
of had a follow-up yeah please which is
what i think is the more relevant thing
and i kind of wanted to frame that
because you do do an excellent job of
like laying that out
so how do we uh how do we use this to
engage with like these institutions that
control us
and create tautologies
that we can kind of break down and see
are just objectively false
that yet they stick to them and then
even you know utilize other legal means
and like means of power to uh to keep
them
to keep
kind of these these things true like
i'll use that in quotes i see that as a
really different question that's less
about convincing any individual with the
tools i mentioned
that's really more about how can just
the people
get
um substantive access to those
institutions where often the access is
reserved for corporations and
high-powered donors so that's a more
systemic question to me than one about
what are like the the rhetorical tools
that might be used
okay
all right well thank you very much i
appreciate it i i think that's the truth
the way truth is framed i think is one
of the most important things
one of the most important discussions
today and so that's why i uh wanted to
hit on that and thank you so much for
answering my question my pleasure it was
a great question and a very very
important topic one of our long time
sponsors is monk pack offering delicious
sweet granola bars and nut and seed bars
with only one gram of sugar or less two
to three net carbs perfect if you do
keto and 150 calories or under so you
can enjoy a sweet satisfying crunchy
snack without the guilt their granola
bars come in flavors like peanut butter
coconut cocoa chip honey nut my favorite
blueberry almond vanilla
monk pack nut and seed bars come in
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
macadamia white chocolate caramel sea
salt and pumpkin seed cinnamon i've
always found the flavor and texture of
these bars awesome and unique you've got
to try it at least once i think you'll
be hooked and if you don't love monk
pack as much as i do they'll refund all
of your money or exchange the product
you'll also get twenty percent off your
first order when you go to monkpack.com
and enter the code pacman at checkout or
click the link in the description